the general formula for conic is like
this you can see it's ax squared plus BX
y plus C y squared plus DX plus CY plus
F equals zero and what we want to focus
in on are the coefficients in front of
the x squared term and the y squared
term so that's the a and the C value
here so if a and C are exactly the same
okay say they're it's 2x squared and
this is 2y squared if they're exactly
the same sign and the same number then
we know that it's a circle if a is 0 or
C is 0 but they're not both 0 then that
means it's a parabola so what what I
mean by that is that if you have like a
y squared term but no x squared term or
vice versa so you have an x squared term
but no y squared term then you know it's
a parabola and then if a and C are
different numbers but they have the same
sign meaning that they're both positive
or they're both negative so you have
like a positive x squared and a positive
Y squared or a negative x squared and a
negative Y squared but if these numbers
are different then it's an ellipse and
then the last one is that if a and C are
different signs meaning if this is a
positive and this is a negative looking
about positive x squared and negative Y
squared or vice versa then you know you
have a hyperbola so let's go through
some examples here and see if you can
identify you know whether it's a
parabola lip circle hyperbola et cetera
but before I do that I just want to
mention that if you're preparing for the
AC T or the SAT check out my huge AC T
math review video course or my huge SAT
math review video course those are
available for sale through the link
below or on my website or on the about
page on my youtube channel so if you're
preparing close tests and you want to go
over some concepts and look at teaching
and examples and prepare yourself better
for scoring high on that test definitely
check out those video courses but let's
go through these examples here so we've
got the first one 3x squared minus 4y
squared plus 6x minus 8y plus 10 equals
0 ok so what we want to zero in on is we
want to zero in on the coefficient in
front of the x squared term and the
coefficient in front of the Y squared
term you can see that there are
different numbers and there are also
different signs this is positive this is
negative so when they're different signs
a and C okay the coefficients in front
of x squared + y squared we know that we
have a hyper
so this one right here will just write
h4 hyperbola okay the next one we've got
five x squared plus 5y squared so on and
so forth but again we're trying to zero
in on that coefficient in front of the x
squared term and the y squared term here
you can see that there are exactly the
same sign they're exactly the same
number you can see a is equal to C so we
know it's a circle okay in the next one
we'll put C for circle for this one for
the next one you can see the coefficient
in front of the x squared term is one
the coefficient in front of the y
squared term is positive two you can see
that they have the same sign meaning
that they're both positive okay but
they're different numbers so that means
that it's an ellipse okay if they were
the same sign and the same number then
we'd have a circle like we had the one
just above it so this one's an ellipse
okay and then this one letter D you can
see that we have a coefficient in front
of our x squared term there's not a y
squared term so that tells us that this
is a parabola okay and then the last one
we've got three y squared plus y plus
four X minus seven you can see there's
not an x squared term here just a y
squared term so again we have another
parabola so this is a quick way to just
identify when you're given this in the
general form like this whether you have
a circle ellipse hyperbola parabola
check out some of the other videos that
I did talking about how to write these
in the standard form of a circle or
ellipse or hyperbola parabola I have
those videos on my youtube channel
Mario's math tutoring subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos over there and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon